Một số kinh xác đã thiệt mạng khi làm nhiều vụ.
Cái đây là giữ hiểu lao thang vượt xanh ngoài quân khổ biểu tình thông thường.
Theo thông tin từ giới chức ở Nguyen Nhân Bũ Trang là bị chếp phá.
Trong đó, có các nghi phạm bị cáo buộc nhận chỉ đạo từ nước ngoài.
Một số trường hợp bị xa định có lên hệ với một sát, các quan tình báo hội xer ạ.
Êi văn cáo buộc tình thông thường.
Này lời dùng tình hình kinh tình thêm khó khăn để kinh đọt bạo lực.
Gây bắt ổng giá hội.
Chính quyền tiê ra khẩn định sẽ tu thu phân biệt giữa biểu tình ổ ngoài và các hình thì bạo lực có tổ chức.
Đồng thời kêu gọi mọi người dân cạnh giác với các nhân tổ gây kinh đọt có chú định.
Phía Isor Ravitude ra phản huổi chính thức về cá mục nó trên.
Chuy đó, thì Mỹ kinh báo hả nâng căn thiệp.
Nếu ý ra đàn đã biểu tình bạo lực, con Isor Ravite tổ ủng hộ các khu biểu tình.